por aquí a la izquierda tenemos un
alcohol terciario este carbono que está
enlazado con el grupo h es el carbono
alfa y está enlazado con otros 3
carbonos por eso decimos que es un
alcohol terciario estos 3 carbonos son
carbonos beta a este le vamos a llamar
el carbono beta 1 este va a ser vetados
y este beta 3 ahora
si hacemos reaccionar un alcohol
terciario con ácido sulfúrico y le
aplicamos calor a la reacción lo que
tenemos es un mecanismo de reacción e1 y
bueno en algunos minutos vamos a hablar
acerca de la región química y de por qué
esta reacción es región selectiva pero
primero veamos paso por paso como sucede
este mecanismo sabemos que lo primero
que sucede es que este alcohol es pro
tornado por el ácido sulfúrico pero
bueno para no dibujar todo el diagrama
de puntos del ácido sulfúrico aquí
simplemente voy a poner un hidrógeno con
carga positiva porque el ácido sulfúrico
es una fuente de protones ahora lo que
sucede aquí es que uno de los pares de
electrones del oxígeno llega y se lleva
al protón de hidrógeno así es que el
primer paso de esta reacción es una
transferencia de protón
este oxígeno está enlazado con dos
hidrógenos y tiene ya nada más un par de
electrones libres y por supuesto tenemos
una carga positiva en este oxígeno lo
que está sucediendo es que este par de
electrones libres del oxígeno recoge un
protón del ácido sulfúrico para formar
este enlace y eso nos da una molécula de
agua como grupo saliente y sabemos que
las moléculas de agua son muy buenos
grupos salientes los electrones de este
enlace pueden irse con el oxígeno para
formar una molécula de agua y cuando eso
sucede estamos quitándole un enlace a
este carbono que estoy dibujando de rojo
así es que estamos formando un carbó
catión el carbono rojo es este carbono
de aquí que es un kart vocaciòn que
tiene una carga formal positiva y por
cierto es un kart vocación terciario
porque está enlazado con otros
es carbonos así es que es un kart
vocación estable ahora vamos a pensar en
el siguiente paso del mecanismo de
reacción es uno una base como ésta que
tenemos aquí llega y se lleva uno de los
protones de uno de los carbonos beta
puede ser cualquiera de estos tres
carbonos beta así es que pues vamos a
empezar por el carbono beta 2 ok
entonces aquí el carbono beta 2 tiene un
protón y tenemos aquí nuestra base débil
que se lleva este protón y entonces los
electrones de este enlace se mueven para
formar un doble enlace así es que
dibujamos por aquí el producto final y
lo que pasó es que los electrones de
este enlace se movieron para formar este
doble enlace y así es como obtenemos
este al que no esto es lo que sucede
cuando la base toma un protón del
carbono beta 2 del carbono beta 2
qué pasaría si la base débil hubiera
tomado un protón de cualquiera de los
otros carbonos vamos a empezar viendo
qué pasa si toma un protón del carbono
beta 1 empezamos dibujando la molécula
otra vez con su kart vocación
este es el kart vocación que tiene una
carga formal positiva ahora la base va a
tomar un protón del carbono beta 1
entonces aquí está el carbono beta 1 y
vamos a dibujar uno de sus protones
tenemos una base débil que llega y se
lleva a este protón por cierto esta base
podría ser una molécula de agua pero
entonces los electrones de este enlace
se quedan entre estos dos carbonos
formando un doble enlace dibujemos ese
producto y así es cómo queda este
producto pero a ver los electrones de
este enlace se mueven para acá formando
el doble enlace formando un al que no
pero espera un momento estas dos
moléculas
calidad son la misma molécula es
exactamente el mismo compuesto químico
aquí no estamos formando dos productos
distintos si le quitamos un protón al
carbono beta 2 o al carbono beta 1 vamos
a obtener exactamente el mismo al que no
bueno pero qué pasa si le quitamos un
protón al carbono beta 3 vamos a volver
a dibujar a esta molécula cuando tiene
un kart vocación éste era el carbono
alfa que ahora es un kart vocación con
carga positiva es un kart vocación
terciario muy estable pero ahora le
vamos a quitar un protón al carbono beta
3 así es que lo dibujamos y una base
débil llega y se lleva a este protón y
los electrones que estaban formando ese
enlace se pasan para acá para formar un
enlace doble
que dibujemos este producto los
electrones de este enlace se movieron
para acá o sea para acá formando este
doble enlace ahorita ya terminamos de
hacer todo el mecanismo y lo que
obtenemos en total son dos productos
distintos
este es un solo producto y este es
nuestro segundo producto sin embargo
cuando realizamos esta reacción el 90%
de las veces
obtenemos el al que no de la derecha y
sólo el 10 por ciento de las veces
obtenemos el de la izquierda así es que
vamos a fijarnos en el grado de
sustitución de éstos al que nos
empezando por el de la derecha por aquí
si dibujamos el hidrógeno que nos falta
de este enlace doble así podemos notar
más fácilmente que tenemos aquí tres
grupos al kilos
tenemos este grupo al kilo y
este y este este es un al que no trees
substituido y ahora vamos a ver el al
que no de la izquierda aquí en este al
que no tenemos estos dos carbonos en el
enlace doble y podemos dibujar los
hidrógenos de los carbonos de este
enlace doble y aquí el carbono de la
derecha tiene dos grupos al kilos por lo
tanto este es un al que no ha sustituido
pero bueno ya terminamos con esta
reacción pero vamos a seguir con ella y
aquí la tenemos nuevamente ahora como
vimos esta reacción tiene productos de
sustituidos y tres sustituidos ahora
vamos a pensar en la región química en
el caso de esta reacción
tenemos que pensar acerca de donde se
forma el enlace doble en el producto de
sustituido el enlace doble se forma en
esta región de la molécula y en el
producto 3 sustituido se forma en esta
región
el producto tree sustituido es el
producto mayor y además es el al que no
más estable si recordamos el vídeo
acerca de la estabilidad de los al que
nos ha y vimos que los al que nos más
sustituidos son los más estables así es
que este producto es más estable y por
eso se forma más este producto y por
cierto al producto más estable al más
sustituido se le llama el producto de
sites efe entonces decimos que esta
reacción a uno es región selectiva
porque tiene una preferencia para formar
productos más estables a los que le
llamamos los productos de sites efe